[Music]
climate and health took center stage in
the third citizens panel over the
weekend
200 citizens of all ages from every eu
country shared ideas on a global
strategy to face climate change like
using alternative energy sources greener
transport and involving all levels of
society
i think environmental issues are now the
most important things that we have to
take into account to to look for the
future because if we don't
make any efforts now we will not have a
future
they also discussed a joint eu approach
to health care ways to promote mental
health how to care for an aging
population and access to reproductive
health for all
further merging our efforts
towards
providing accessibility to health care
from one corner of europe to the other i
think
this sounds like a goal
[Music]
twenty participants will represent the
panel and explain its ideas to the
conference plenary
proposals made by the panels will help
shape the conference's recommendations
in spring 2022
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you